this is Ansel Elgort and I'm Suki
Waterhouse today we're doing a wired
auto-complete interview we're gonna give
you the real answers yeah
because Google can be fickle sometimes
[Music]
Suzanne talk of a brother I met your
brother yes yeah your brother how do you
feel about my brother it was awesome
it's a filmmaker 1 or 2 I have one
brother ok one brother does Ansel over
have a kid this is my announcement I'll
have a cameo in Paper Towns it would be
it wouldn't be a surprise cameo if I
told you that I had a cameo Beaver Dam
no but the movies come out so I know but
if you've seen it yet you don't know
about it do you have a cameo no no you
don't see she hasn't seen it I haven't
seen it do you but some questions are
not meant to be answered I'll go out
love shailene woodley yeah hello
shailene woodley she's so cool she's the
best does Ansel Elgort sing no I'm not
that I know
I'm so sorry sound person what face
shape does Suki Waterhouse have like a
melon square what movies is Suki what
else been in movies Suki minun no no
wait which movies have you been into
Keiko Itsuki once I was like 5 insurgent
yeah yeah and Jonathan which is coming
out what height is Suki Waterhouse Ravi
no I'm even shorter than that 5 7 yeah
yeah actually that's what does Suki
Waterhouse eat well what I just was just
eating maggots no I was just having all
those all those little sausages yeah we
were eating a hotel and we had something
so much only meat we only ate my machi
veggie sausages oh you had here is absol
Elgort single how did you live under a
rock single yeah then there's something
wrong with you no the answer is not
single Oh God not single Freudian slip
is answer
Russian da privyet
I mean I take my mic my father is a
little bit but okay so you're a little
bit Russian but he's from New York but
you have like a tiny bit freshmen but in
you Russian blood it ain't all work dope
dope
are you adopted no I think he might be
adopted I'm not his ansel elgort an
amputee no I'm not no I played a
character once in a movie called Fault
in Our Stars that was an amputee his
hands auger nominated for Golden Globe I
was so baby driving right do you still
hold a nomination if you lose okay how
older Sookie what does 26 how to get
Suki Waterhouse hair threw out your
hairbrush never wash your hair just be
gross
how much is Suki Waterhouse worth not
much how to dress like Suki Waterhouse
go spend all your money's on your
clothes that's not true because actually
mine it's not even mine it's my friends
as I wouldn't be good I wouldn't even
purchase something like that you
wouldn't I would yeah it's sick oh
except to save up because I'm not worth
much thank you
dude Ansel Elgort win an Oscar yeah the
dance Oliver go to college no can you
tell how did Ansel Elgort become famous
once upon a time there was a little boy
called Ansel I did a movie called The
Fault in Our Stars the one where I was
amputated and stuff in case you're
wondering like where the hell is this
Angela right from I hate him that's
where I'm from that movie okay
did Ansel Elgort write supernova yeah I
did I wrote that song oh you have a song
good I do yeah it's okay you haven't
heard it I guess the answer over keep
the Subaru yeah I did
I kept the Subaru
from baby driver the other movie that
made me famous a Suki Waterhouse
Japanese I'm not Japanese but my parents
gave me a Japanese name they just got
excited because I was their first child
and they were like woo his Suki
Waterhouse in natural blonde I mean I
was when I was a kid yeah but God knows
what it is now where is Suki Waterhouse
from I am from Chyzyk in London
I'm fully English it's really boring
it's just like Englishness Suki
Waterhouse what does it say relating to
gia Waterhouse gay Waterhouse do you
know who gave water hazards I'm actually
allergic to horses so I don't think I am
when uncle birthday March 14th 1994 when
does ansel elgort album come out
I don't know I'm working on it now by
the end of the summer I think maybe okay
when did Ansel Elgort die
thank God so sad for our loss